dans cette usine qui fabrique du verre
pour les panneaux solaires on s'inquiète
de plus en plus de la dépendance au gaz
russe c'est le kremlin décidé de couper
le robinet comme il vient de le faire
pour la pologne et la bulgarie alors 300
emplois seraient en danger
un arrêt de l'approvisionnement en gaz
russe signifie répond nous un arrêt de
la production c'est pourquoi nous y
sommes clairement opposés dépendant du
gaz naturel russe parce que nous n'avons
pas d'autre option d'approvisionnement
à l'échelle nationale les conséquences
seraient bien plus grave et pourrait
faire basculer le pays dans la récession
l'allemagne a pourtant pris des mesures
pour réduire sa dépendance à la russie
berlin estime pouvoir prochainement se
passer du pétrole russe grâce à des
fournisseurs alternatifs
mais couper l'approvisionnement en gaz
semble plus compliqué car la guerre en
ukraine a fait flamber le prix de
l'énergie est plombé la confiance des
consommateurs
ces dernières semaines nous avons
constaté des augmentations drastique des
prix du mazout du gaz et de l'essence en
conséquence l'inflation en allemagne est
actuellement supérieure à 7% c'est le
niveau le plus élevé que nous ayons
connue en 40 ans cela réduit le pouvoir
d'achat le président allemand a mais
l'erreur commise par son pays en étant
aussi dépendant de l'énergie russe
l'année dernière moscou a fourni plus de
la moitié du gaz naturel utilisé en
allemagne et environ un tiers de la
consommation de pétrole